another major story this weekend of huge
geopolitical and foreign policy
importance
is that long-time israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu of the likud
party is finally out as prime minister
replaced by the incoming prime minister
naftali bennett in israel much of what
takes place is coalition based and so
what we have seen here is that by
a single vote margin uh naftali bennett
is in and benjamin netanyahu is out
because of the coalition that bennett
was able to form the new york times
reports
the long and divisive reign of benjamin
netanyahu the dominant
israeli politician of the past
generation officially ended on sunday at
least for the time being
as the country's parliament gave its
vote of confidence to a precarious
coalition government
stitched together by widely disparate
anti-netanyahu forces
israelis israel's parliament the knesset
approved the new government by just a
single vote 60-59
with one abstention after his supporters
cheered the announcement of his election
naftali bennett then exchanged a brief
handshake with netanyahu
before walking to the rostrum at the
front of the parliamentary chamber
and taking the oath of office as prime
minister yair lapida centrist leader
is set to take mr bennett's place after
two years if their government can hold
together that long
they lead an eight-party alliance
ranging from left to right
from secular to religious that agrees on
little but a desire to oust netanyahu
the longest serving leader in the
country's history and to end
israel's lengthy political gridlock
in a speech made before the confidence
vote bennett hailed his unlikely
coalition
as an essential antidote to an
intractable stalemate
we stopped the train before the abyss
bennett said the time has come for
different leaders from all parts of the
people
to stop to stop this madness now you
will remember
that netanyahu as the article points out
and his right-wing allies from likud and
other far-right parties
did everything they could i i mean i
guess maybe there was something else
they could have done something
illegal i don't know they did almost
everything they could they applied
pressure
on other right-wing opposition lawmakers
they were trying to peel them away
uh from possibly being on the bennett
side but ultimately unable to
do it the question of course now is
what happens next it's important to
understand
that while uh naftali bennett is not
a likudnik uh the party likud of
benjamin netanyahu
there is the this political alliance
yamina
which is an alliance of right-wing
parties including
what was originally the new right uh and
and some other parties and we will see
ultimately how it shakes out in practice
now
it is still a right-wing coalition and
is still naftali bennett is still a
right-winger
um and it is a real question mark as to
as to what progress if any will be able
to be made
in terms of the israeli-palestinian
conflict now on the other side as i said
before
it is a requirement but it is necessary
but not sufficient
to remove benjamin netanyahu is there if
there is going to be any serious chance
at
peace talks that could be productive and
and permanent or semi-permanent as we
may call it
on the other side of that um hamas
we know simply cannot be
will not be they refuse to be there is
no way that hamas will be a party
to any kind of serious peace talks and
hamas seems potentially as ingrained as
ever
uh in gaza um hamas near if you want to
understand sort of the outrageous
dynamics of what's going on there
hamas recently awarded al jazeera an
award which al jazeera
gladly accepted for their coverage of
the recent
conflict there and for anybody who has
um
legitimate criticism of the way that the
recent flare up
with gaza was covered by certain
media outlets but does not have uh
concerns
about the coverage of for example al
jazeera which was recently given an
award by hamas
you're sort of missing half of the
picture so i remain extremely
skeptical as to the progress that will
be made in the next
two years serious progress when it comes
to the israeli-palestinian conflict but
removing benjamin netanyahu as prime
minister was step you know 0.1
it was a necessary step it is not
sufficient
and we will now see what happens next it
would be amazing
if there were able to be at least some
um
initial hypothetical guidelines set out
for some kind of serious path forward
but something that's important to
understand is
you know one of the risks of
casually following the internal politics
of other countries
is no matter who you follow like whether
you're following the new york times
and the times of israel or whether
you're following
al jazeera for your understanding of the
israeli-palestinian conflict
you sometimes miss the forest for the
trees and one of the things that is
really important to understand is that
within israel meaning to israelis
the israeli-palestinian conflict does
not actually rank particularly high
in terms of the concerns that the
israeli people have for what they want
a prime minister or the new prime
minister to focus on it's mostly
internal issues
it's internal issues related to
economics it's internal issues related
to
education and social services and
infrastructure
much like in the united states and it's
not different in that sense and this is
something that is really missed
when you look at israel and the
israeli-palestinian conflict
through any kind of western media
whether it's hard right or whether it's
hard left or whether it's centrist
our lens tends to be foreign policy of
israel and the israeli-palestinian
conflict
much like in the united states foreign
policy listen
in the middle of a completely
harebrained war with iraq
in 2004 uh george w bush
still was re-elected and the war in iraq
which
was like we went to war with the wrong
country over a lie about the connection
between saddam and 911. that's insane
and even that only got the war in iraq
to
a reasonably important issue for
americans the primary issues were still
domestic economic et cetera it's no
different in israel
and i think that that's a really
important detail to understand
as anybody from outside of israel tries
to follow and understand what it is
that's going on there so netanyahu out
that's the good news
below that a whole bunch of other
details that
um raise questions that have not yet
been answered
send me your thoughts about what you
expect if anything to change
with the removal of benjamin netanyahu
you can find me on twitter at deepakman
we will take a break what a packed show
today it's really a big one
during the pandemic and even at this
point i try to avoid
physically visiting a doctor's office
unless i really have to and that's why i
love our sponsor
steadymd primary care you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician who's a good fit for you
you have a one-hour virtual appointment
and you start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone and video chat and
unlike other services this isn't some
random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they can give you
the personal attention you deserve
they can help you with anything your
primary care doctor
normally would healthy diet managing
conditions weight loss
sleep depression anxiety you don't need
insurance
it's just 99 a month with absolutely no
other fees or co-pays for visits
take the free quiz and see which doctor
is a perfect fit for you
go to steadymd.com pacman there's no
risk
no long-term commitment the link is
right underneath this video